(mysterious music)
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Okay it's Tea ♪
♪ With Gary Vee ♪
♪ Sippin' in the beat ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Puttin' out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea With Gary Vee ♪
♪ Michael make a flip ♪
- Good morning.
Team Gary Vee, April 28th, Tuesday.
Hope everybody is doing
super well with their fams.
Let's just get right into the show.
See what's up with this video clip.
Hey, Nicole.
- Hey there.
Man, this is so cool meeting you!
- Thank you.
- I'm excited!
How are you?
- I'm quite well.
Where are you right now?
- I'm in Amsterdam right now
in my studio in the city,
so safe and sound.
- Good, good.
What can I help you with?
What's your question?
- So I prepared a custom
questions for you.
So my first question that came
into my mind immediately is
if you were a musician,
what would be the first steps
you would do to reach your
audience like, from scratch.
- I would create a social media profile,
on TikTok, Instagram, YouTube, Twitter,
minimally, most likely Facebook.
I would upload music on a daily basis
if I had the ability to
produce that much music.
My fascination with musicians
is how much music they sit on.
The insecurity of having it perfect
or that they think,
their subjective opinion
of their own music,
is the right one.
When we've had a history
of people telling us
that the song that they
least liked on their album
became the breakout song
that changed their career.
So I would produce content
at scale telling my story.
Who am I, why is this,
my dad loved the trumpet,
my grandma taught.
Like I would put out
content of my origin story.
I would put out content of
other musicians I liked.
just taking a photo of me.
If I was a writer, I
would like start a song.
And like if I was three sentences in,
I would take a photo of it and post it
and tell people I'm working on something.
Imagine having that post of like,
John Lennon writing "Imagine".
Like you know, you know.
- That would be insane.
- Yeah, so I would I would do what I do.
Like if I was, if I was a musician,
I'd be one of the biggest
musicians in the world,
because I'm very good at communication.
You know, I'm a businessman,
and I have this much
awareness and notoriety
out of my ability to be a good
communicator and storyteller
on digital platforms.
If I had the ammo of actual music?
You know, my best keynotes
can get a million views.
My best songs would get a billion views.
Right, so--
- Most definitely,
and that's what I love about you
because that I think
there are two people that
I just go to on YouTube.
That's you and Casey Neistat.
And I was just wondering
if you would you know,
it's something that you keep
repeating within your videos.
And sometimes I do have
to admit immediately
that I lack in that specific area because,
you know, sometimes I feel like,
just having time for myself
and like social media
can completely consume.
But--
- That's good, that's good
That doesn't bother me.
Like I actually genuinely don't worry
about how much people put out
if they need time to themselves.
I'm more worried about two things.
One, when they are ready to put out,
are they insecure,
which is why they're
not putting things out?
Or two, have they not put in the work
to understand the functions
of how the platforms work?
So is it insecurity or lack of grit,
when you're ready?
That's what I'm worried about,
not that you need four
days a week to not be on.
I'm like, great.
Then tell me about the
three days you are on.
- Are on, yeah.
- You know, and so and with musicians,
my biggest issue is
they just sit on music.
You know, like to me that --
- I think it's different,
because some musicians,
for instance, in my case,
I work with Roc Nation,
so I cannot be like,
"Oh, you know, guys
tomorrow I have like a 10 --
- I got it, I got it.
- Song album I could
(crosstalk)
- But honestly, I get it.
So honestly, if I was
if I was in the place
where I became aware of that,
and I would fulfill my album requirements.
And I would use hip-hop
culture and say look,
why are hip-hop artists
allowed to put out mixtapes,
which is free music to build awareness?
I want to put out a mixtape.
- Okay.
- You know what I mean?
Listen --
- Okay that's a gem.
- The way people win in music
is the easiest game of all time.
They have a song that changes
the course of their career.
- Yeah.
- Like, all of them, all of them.
The Beatles, Madonna,
Michael Jackson, Prince.
One song.
If you're a legend, or if you're great,
you'll have more than one song.
If you're not,
sometimes you're a one hit wonder
but you still had a pretty fun career.
But, I don't understand how
musicians don't understand,
that they need to put out the music.
They think that if the songs are bad,
it could hurt them.
I know that there's tons
of songs even by the greats
that the world hasn't loved.
- I don't believe it
will hurt you, I guess
and I do say I agree with your point.
But I believe that I mean,
I made I think together like
six projects since 2009.
Believe me, if you're the first
project, you'll be giggling,
you know, when this camera
goes off, you'll be like.
(giggling)
Because it's, it's totally
not what I am today.
But I do believe that it was necessary
to have that journey to
become where you are,
or actually travel the journey,
you know, for the things
you'd like to reach.
So I definitely agree with you.
- I got it.
- So before you let me go,
because I know you're a busy man,
I have one more question.
If you could do everything
from scratch again,
your businesses to the
entrepreneurships that you're doing,
and you could take the
knowledge you have today.
What would be the first mentally change
you would give --
- [Offscreen Woman] Apply?
- Apply, thank you.
- I would personally probably,
go on one or two more vacations in my 20s.
Because I was too 100%.
So for me it would be
a little bit more balance
in my personal life.
Professionally, nothing different.
- Okay, beautiful.
- That's it, thank you Nicole.
- Alright, thank you so much.
- Take care, bye bye.
Dustin, I'm seeing a lot of comments
that my levels are down, what's up?
Can you hear me?
- Yeah, I mean, I can hear
you, but it is really low.
Can you just try --
- What?
- Just I dunno, go like this or something.
- How 'bout now?
- Just do a test.
- One two seven nine four seven.
- I don't know why I hear myself.
I don't know why I hear myself.
- How 'bout now?
- It's still pretty bad.
- That sucks, hold on.
- I think he's gonna go for the air pods.
And everyone that's keep
commenting "adjust the audio",
I can't adjust the audio, I can't.
We are working on it.
Yeah, it's just not happening right now.
- How 'bout now?
- It's still pretty quiet.
- It's still quiet.
(clicking)
- Now?
- It's a little better.
- I was going pretty loud there though.
How 'bout right now?
- It's about the same.
Do you wanna just use a speaker?
- Unfortunately, the
speaker you were saying
it's not really good.
- I think that this sounds better,
but I hear myself, but --
- One two seven
four seven seven seven four seven, 14.
Put me on without you on
I just wanna hear what people say.
Yo, what's up guys, can you hear me?
Like actually let me go normal voice.
What are you guys hearing?
Is it better?
Echo?
How 'bout now, great?
Yes, it's good.
Alright, alright let's just
go with this sound then.
I need to go with my,
I think I need to go with my air pods.
I'll be right back.
Dustin, keep them entertained.
- Okay, okay.
So yeah that's a curtain.
It's kinda pale lookin'.
That's a chair that you
see right next to his name.
Gary's on mute.
(laughing)
I think that's why I was echoing,
'cause it was probably my voice
going back into his computer.
So how about those Knicks?
I don't watch any sports,
so I'm just talking out of my ass.
I'm looking through the comments here.
"The echo is gone".
That's because I've muted Gary.
There's too many comments coming in,
I can't read it all.
(chuckles)
So, yeah.
Oh, anyone that wants to
know what we're using,
qe're not using OBS, Zoom
and Restream anymore,
this is just strictly StreamYard.
Caleb said, "Talk about
the evolution of Tea Time."
Well, that is true.
Yeah, we started doing this as like,
just Zoom and OBS and
it was super scrappy,
and I didn't like the way the quality was.
The video quality was terrible,
so we had to switch.
(echoes)
Yep, I'm still hear myself.
- Right, what about now?
- Yeah, I think that's better.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Awesome, let's rock and roll.
- Cool.
- Yo.
- Brett, what's good?
- Gary, pleasure.
Big fan.
- Thank you, sir.
- You're a motivator,
you motivate our whole team and company,
so I appreciate all that you do.
- Thank you, sir.
- So at first I want to say
for all my team that's listening,
I want you to get out there and fail
as best you can.
- Yeah, the relationship with "no"
and the relationship with failing
and the relationship with losing
is the quickest path to actual happiness.
- Well, as long as we
fail and learn from it,
we're gonna come out ahead.
That's been the goal of our success.
- I appreciate that.
- But for you and for anybody listening,
I own a bunch of liquor brands.
I don't know if you Gary,
I don't know if you know them.
My past brands were, Ace of
Spades, Armand de Brignac --
- Oh, of course.
- And then I started a brand
that we still own a piece
of called D'usse Cognac.
- Know it well.
- And then Belaire,
that's our one of our newer ones.
You know Belaire?
- Know it extremely well.
- And then--
- Wine Library
Wine Library carries all three.
- Thank you, and you carry Bumbu?
- I don't know,
I'm not sure if they do or not.
- This is--
- I'm --
- It's the fastest growing
premium rum in the world today.
- Good for you.
- We're about to take over
the number one position,
which is exciting.
But to me, it's a perfect time to ask you
about what you're doing differently now
with respect to social media.
- Well I think --
- Brand.
- And, and, and kind of in
the context of your world.
So obviously, you've
done an incredible job.
You know, obviously, the first two brands
with one of the biggest
stars in the world,
and I've seen what
you've done with Belaire
with different individuals
as well in, in hip-hop and in culture
and in different areas.
I think, I think the same way,
you know, I think, you know,
without knowing the
details, like obviously,
I think the people that
understand how to build brand
understand how to build brand.
So it doesn't confuse me
that you're doing well across the board,
because we all find,
you know, people think it's
people think it's so simple.
I don't think it's as simple as saying,
"Hey, Jay-Z let's do this thing",
and then it works.
There's so many things that
is on your head and your team's head
to actually make that work.
Motivating salespeople in the,
in the archaic three-tier system,
creating brand for other segments
that aren't affected by Jay-Z or DJ Khaled
or things of that nature are fabulous.
You know, like, there's so much other work
that needs to be get done
to build a sustainable brand.
I think it's about arbitrage
of where attention is.
Right?
So, for example, you may be
aware if you're watching this,
how much I've been pushing WineText.
Yesterday, we had a
single piece of creative
on the WineText side that
is working on Facebook,
that is driving subscriptions at economics
that are sustainable, unlike before.
Meaning if we have an average of $88
in value of a customer
that signs up for WineText,
that advertises all 10s of
thousands of people on it,
you know, now that we can
pay $32 for a subscription,
that becomes a real life business.
Right?
So what am I doing different?
Couple things.
One, when you look at
things like Fashion Nova,
or or other things that have happened in,
you know, Motive Watch
or things that nature.
I think for your brands,
there is a much longer
tail of micro-influencers,
of an ambassador program
that I think would really work well.
It's kind of the scaled long-tail version
of what I think you've done well
in building these brands
without knowing the details,
but knowing people associated with it.
Two, I think there's an
incredible opportunity
now that TikTok is oh is gonna,
is allowing liquor brands
from an ad standpoint,
but from an organic standpoint,
TikTok has exploded in 21 to 45 year olds.
And I think your brands
have a ton of permission
to play there.
Obviously, if you're not on
top of every little nuance,
you know, it could feel
a little uncomfortable
to go in there because it's
kids and this is alcohol.
But the reality is there's a threshold
when the percentage of,
there's unlimited kids on Instagram,
and Twitter and other places as well
once it hits a certain threshold.
So I think TikTok's a huge
place to look at as well.
And then honestly,
you know, just getting a
look at you and like really,
you know look, I'm hoping this
is the start of us getting
to know each other.
I think you yourself,
should probably start putting out content,
where people become,
you know, Empathy Wines.
You know half of that product is selling
based on people being fans
of me as an entrepreneur,
who happen to drink wine.
I think as people become
fans of you as a marketer,
as a personality I mean
how great you look,
let alone the successes
you have under your belt,
and I'm sure there was a lot of
failures and successes along the way
that got you to this place.
I think as people become
more fascinated by you,
I think there's probably
an arbitrage of saying,
"Oh, I like this guy.
"He helped me through my journey."
Whatever that may be,
"Oh, well, why am I buying this rum?
I'm gonna start buying his rum."
And I think there's actually
a big arbitrage there
and a big opportunity potentially
for you as well there.
Maybe in something like
podcast or vlog form.
Look, this is simple.
It's whoever's a media company wins.
You know, Walter Cronkite won,
'cause everybody in America watched him.
Jay-Z wins 'cause
everybody watches him like,
it's just attention.
It's the simplest game of all time.
Where's the good deal of attention?
Why set up and pour for free
at a concert or a festival or a thing?
'Cause through the last 50
years of alcohol marketing,
because it's there's tension
there, and there's trial,
and if they think it's delicious,
they start considering it and they buy it.
I think, I think the modern
ways of attention, this is it.
I don't even I don't.
You have to start here.
You can worry about being a sponsor
of Coachella or Rolling Loud
or you can worry about t-shirts
for, you know, salespeople,
or you can worry about that shit later.
But if you're not a
dominator on the cell phone,
on the mobile device and the
15 platforms that win there.
A dominator, a real YouTube strategy,
a real LinkedIn strategy,
a real Twitter strategy,
you're leaving enormous
economics on the table.
- From my perspective and
the way we look at things,
and we're, you know.
I think we've got great brands
and they've all been built the same way,
having no money,
and it's my money.
And sometimes, you know,
you're looking at it from the perspective
of well, I got to be different.
I got to stand out.
I can't compete with the
Diageo's and the Pernod Ricards--
- 'Course.
- These giant
liquor companies.
- Of course not.
- So in this environment now,
where basically, you know,
purchasing power is
decreased so significantly,
people are scared as well.
- Well, You know, sorry
to interrupt Brett,
like, and I'll let you
finish your thought.
Purchasing power is interesting, right?
Because E-commerce had its
greatest two weeks of all time,
because people got their $1200
stimulus check and bought.
America, even during the Great Depression,
when it was buying makeup,
or during the Great Recession,
where tons of luxury brands were built.
You know, don't ever underestimate
that we live in the most
capitalistic consumer-centric,
you know, society that
has ever been built.
So, you know, knowing that
you've got premium brands
and things of that nature.
(chuckles)
You know, this yes, it becomes
a game of who's better now.
- Sure,
- You'll have to be better,
but it's staggering to me
how much purchasing power there still is
even when 40-fucking-five
million people are out of a job.
- Yeah.
- We're built on credit!
- But then and --
- We're not attached
to the gold standard.
Like we have incredible economic power
even at our worst.
It's crazy, it's fascinating.
- Sure but --
- Go ahead.
- I think but in some ways,
the last thing I want
is someone with that $1200
check to be buying my products.
- Me too!
- You know--
- Right?
It scares the fuck out of me.
- Yeah.
The problem is you can't
stop these fuckers.
- Sure.
- I'm putting out content every day,
save, save, save, save.
- Yeah.
- And then they're buying
you know, six $60 pinot
noirs from me on WineText.
I'm looking at it I'm like,
"Man, I hope that person has $360."
You know, like it's scary!
Did Brett freeze?
He looks so good too.
Dustin.
- He may have froze--
- No,
this guy's so cool
that he might be doing
like some sort of like
meditation trance on us right now.
Yeah he's like pretty epic.
Alright let's get the next person in,
and then work on him
and we let him finish his thought
and we'll have him come back in.
- Gary!
- What's good?
- Not much man, how are you?
- I'm really well Chris.
- Right on, right on.
Well, hello from Oregon.
- Thank you.
- One of the best
wine capitals in the country.
- I love Oregon.
- So, I'm sure you knew that.
- I do, I do.
- But,
hey, I appreciate your time today.
So, my question a little,
just a little bit of back context for it.
I've had the actual privilege
of failing my way through life.
So I was never super great in school.
And so you can imagine,
like when I found you,
like, that was huge for me, right?
I've actually been fired from four jobs
and was recently fired not that long ago,
which actually spurred
me to start my business.
So the two times that I have like,
thrown myself into my career,
I have been fired,
which is really interesting to me.
The other two times were my fault,
'cause I was young and stupid, right?
So I decided to launch this business
amidst all of this coronavirus craziness,
because I actually I work with
a really great Google Ads agency.
And saw that there was a need out there
and I much like you have a
ability to notice trends.
And I think I'm really hedging on
marketing and audiences,
how we consume and the type
of content that we consume,
I think is going to change pretty big
after the coronavirus hits,
and you know, has come and passed,
like I already see it kind of evolving.
So, my question to you being that I am 31
and if I get a good clean shave,
I look at best 22.
(laughs)
So, how do I get business
owners, entrepreneurs,
to one, you know, just hear me out
but two also to help them understand that,
"Hey, look, what you're
doing is a bad idea."
- So --
- And the only reason
I know that is 'cause I failed.
(laughs)
- Yeah, so, first and foremost,
the huge key for you is to realize
looking young is just another pillar
of you justifying to yourself,
why the person would say no.
It's really understanding, like that,
You should have empathy for somebody
that thinks you look too young, at
or isn't experienced.
Like you need to get a
great relationship with no.
You know, like, you know,
when you're already thinking
about the thought of like,
"Do I look too young?"
Or, "how do I get them
"to think of me seriously
and buy from me?"
What I'm most zeroing in on is like,
"Hey, Chris, don't worry about that!"
Like 93% are gonna say no, anyway.
- Right.
- You know, like,
I was, very similar until I,
you know, until the,
the Russian immigrant,
you know, DNA started
getting into the eyes
and the wrinkles,
but like, I looked quite
young most of my youth.
And, you know, I was
also trying to sell wine
when I was 17 Looking 11.
And of course, everybody said no.
What I think you need to figure
out is, don't even start,
I don't want you to even be thinking
about the reason they're
not gonna take you serious.
I want you to focus
on the three people that
say yes for whatever reason,
out of the 150 you ask,
and then crushing the fuck out of that
and then becoming, that
becoming your reputation.
- Yeah, no that actually
makes a lot of sense.
And I guess I more specifically,
like I'm not worried
about people that say no.
I did sales for 12 years.
- Okay.
- So I'm just eating garbage.
My logo actually that I
created for my business
was community-created.
I had been
basically in sales and marketing
but no logo design work--
- Why why why,
why did you get fired from the two jobs,
like real talk,
like if we're gonna really bring value,
on some real fucking like
you don't even want to
say it out loud shit.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Why do think--
- Yeah.
The first one I think,
that I threw my heart and soul into,
I think that one it
was more of distraction
and not staying focused
on the exact specific jobs
that they wanted me to do.
(crosstalk)
- So you, so you,
so really this is interesting to me.
'Cause there's something going
on in my world right now.
I'm dying to see if
this is what you meant.
So what kind of job was that?
- It was a, it was Wells
Fargo sorry business banking.
- No worries, no worries.
- So I --
- So you had a remit,
but you were so fired up
and so high energy,
were you bleeding into
other people's territories
to show that you could,
and that put you in a precarious spot?
- That's how I've been fired both times.
- Dude, Chris, this is fucking amazing.
I love you right now,
because I'm gonna make a
piece of content right now
that's going to save a lot of people
from a lot of headaches and really help.
You and I right now, are
about to help a lot of people.
- Let's go!
- I can't believe
that's what you just said.
So I've been thinking a
ton about this, Chris.
I see this all the time.
I have seen over the last two decades,
a ton of people get caught in this.
And right now there's a
couple of scenarios I'm seeing
and it's fucking killing me,
and I'm trying to fix it.
And I'm like, I'm just I
know I'm babbling right now
'cause I'm so happy.
There are so many people
that work at jobs,
who, who get their task,
who then start trying to
do other people's jobs
or insert themselves into other places
they don't belong.
And it is 100% based on insecurity.
- So the interesting thing here too is,
I agree with you actually
totally 100%, the --
- Lets stay there for a second,
and then I wanna,
your next question is I wanna help people.
Listen to me.
You're not tricking anybody,
by trying to like, jump
into other people's jobs.
And like, you think you're trying,
you're showing somebody
yourself, usually, but somebody
like, look at all these things I can do.
I'm so capable.
Give me more.
(chuckles)
It's such a tell, it's like poker.
When you're unable to stay in your thing,
and you start meddling
in other people's stuff,
you're trying to make
yourself feel better,
that you're more capable a
lot of times than you are.
You're lacking self awareness,
and then you're exposing yourself.
And all the under conversations
are really gonna get you fired
because people can feel it.
And there's chatter underneath,
and I see it from a lot of people
and people that work at Vayner,
people work in Wine Library
people work in other places,
and I really like them,
and I feel devastated.
And I'm gonna start going
at it a little bit more
more canderous with them,
because it is a very
common thing I'm seeing.
And what I want to tell everybody
and I see the reactions are on fire.
What I want to tell everybody is,
this is so important
for the young Chrisses who went through it
and the others and the
people I'm thinking right now
that I hope we're watching.
You're not tricking anyone.
And I feel like if people knew,
and this is the moment,
like if you knew that nobody's confused,
you're not showing that
you can do a lot of stuff,
you're showing that you're insecure,
and you're trying to overcompensate
for your deep insecurity.
And that you're tricking no one.
No one's confused,
and it's going to lead to bad.
Firing or getting or
getting put into a box
where you're just in the corner.
It's a big deal in our society.
It rears its head a ton.
It's, like it's crazy.
The comments haven't exploded this much,
Chris, in a long time.
Like this is a big one.
And like I love you right now.
You came into my life at this exact second
'cause it's on my mind heavy.
And I and I needed somebody like you
that was honest and could own it.
Like when you said,
the most important moment
in this video, Chris,
was when I delivered what I delivered
and you said, "You're right.
"You're absolutely right."
That was huge.
Because then people, you know,
I'm sitting over here talking about it,
you lived it.
That's important for people.
Chris, it's a big deal
and it's also why you were
worried about looking 22.
Chris I'm telling you right now bro,
the reason you'vebeen
failing through life,
and the reason that I'm your fucking guy.
The reason I'm your fucking guy
is because I was blessed with luck.
I don't feel better than you, I got lucky.
I got lucky with DNA
circumstance and parenting
to have ultimate self-confidence.
You've been unfortunate,
but not crazy unfortunate
'cause you're young as fuck
and we're about to fix it.
- Yeah.
- To not, to not,
and you need to.
That's why I jumped immediately
on the fucking 22-year-old thing.
It's why as soon as you
said the other thing,
I'm like wait a minute this like it's,
literally last night I was
laying in bed thinking about it
'cause I'm think 'bout
three or four people I love
at my company that are in trouble
because of this.
Listen to me, bro.
You have to go deep as fuck
like fucking deep to the root shit.
You can't like cut the flower,
you got to go in the dirt and get.
you know.
- I gotta go deep down.
- You need to realize
that your Mom or Dad,
your DNA, or your circumstance
created insecurity.
You're worried what other people think,
you're not confident
enough to be happy enough.
But you can be and should be.
What you need to do, is flip the switch.
Like it's practice, it's
like working out, right?
Like I used to have like puny
and now at least I have
like a little bit of muscle.
It was work, I do work every day.
You need to do work every day.
Not on some foofy foofy shit
like "I'm good enough",
which probably matters too, by the way
'cause I don't even want
to consider that foofy
but I want you to go intense on this.
Because I'm telling you right now, bro.
You fucking switch that
and realize fuck it.
Like, my big thing on confidence is,
"Don't put anybody else on a pedestal."
Chris, don't put anybody
else on a pedestal.
Don't put me on a pedestal,
don't put anybody on a pedestal!
Once you realize everybody
else has massive shortcomings,
massive shortcomings,
once you realize everybody
else has massive shortcomings,
now you feel on their level.
Not that you're admiring
something you don't have,
'cause guess what?
I admire your hair.
(laughs)
And there's probably
and if I knew you well,
I would probably admire your compassion,
your kindness, your humor,
whatever else, but like,
but like, bro, you need
to work every second
on building up your
self-esteem at all costs,
and it comes in two forms.
One, getting to the root of the cause,
actually going into that therapy session
or by yourself and crying it out
that your mom fucked it up,
that your brother fucked it up
that your dad fucked it up
that your, you know, like,
and then not resenting them.
Being empathetic to them,
realizing their mom or dad
fucked them up, you know?
You need to fucking work on, bro.
- (mumbles)
- I'm telling you right now.
I want you to be happy so bad,
and I listened very carefully.
You've got two tells like in poker
that I know you're deeply insecure,
and I want to fix the fuck out of it.
- Well, I'll get working on it, man,
I'm about it every day, you
got to earn that self-respect.
Every day I earn the right to go to sleep.
So I'm ot it.
- Fuck self but stick with me.
Even the way you said
self-respect, this is good.
This why I wanna jam with you.
This is important bro, you're gonna,
first I want, you're
gonna benefit from it,
but a lot of people are.
Make it all insular.
Make your, try to make your
life about you with you.
- Okay.
- You know, like
earning somebody else's respect
is how you get in trouble
of trying to like do something.
You know, like, fuck that, bro.
Chris, listen to me, fuck them.
- I like that.
- You know.
- Yeah, that's great.
- It will work.
It doesn't mean you have to,
like I love people the most,
I just am not willing to let
their opinions dictate my life.
Chris, they don't know you.
When the SCO comes and they're
like, "Get out of here."
Like, be pumped, not sad
and I mean this, and I'll tell you why.
They just don't know you.
- Yeah.
- It also keeps people grounded.
Do you know why I have humility, Chris?
Because they don't know me.
Meaning like, I'm not some dark evil lord,
but like, like, but like, I
can't take the compliment hard.
Like, you gotta, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, no I know exactly what you mean.
Like they don't know you,
they don't know you're in and outs
what you do every single
day of every single minute.
So what does a compliment or a criticism
actually mean when they're not in?
- It's true, man.
Are you living it,
or are you starting it
or starting to become the
subconscious becoming conscious?
Like where are you on
your journey on this?
'Cause it matters to me.
- Yeah, no, I'm actually
just now realizing
that it's a problem.
I've actually been working on myself.
- Good.
- For the last like,
it's taken a while.
So for like the last three, four years?
I started like really
committing to working on myself.
And I actually told myself two years ago,
"I'm gonna be very Gary Vee someday",
and here we are.
So things take time and
that's why I say like,
I failed my way through life.
Meaning that like, I'm really okay
with that failing aspect
because ultimately it has
led me to where I'm at now.
Clearly I still have --
- Of course.
- Internal problems that I need to work on
and address too.
- It's not problems.
Dude, it's honestly this
is what's so fun about it.
It's not really problems.
I have to work on my candor,
I have to do a much better job
telling people to their face
they're not good at their
job and they have to go.
I suck at it.
I've gone from zero to six, so I'm proud,
but I'm not in 10 land.
People, I'm so canderous on this.
I'm going right at you canderous,
but if you were my employee,
I would dance like a
little fucking ballerina.
- (laughs) That's funny.
- I mean it!
I'm telling you truth,
that's not fun for me to say!
That onstage and on Tea With Gary Vee.
I am uncomfortably canderous,
but once something becomes my family,
I struggle because the love goes deeper
and some, something over
the hook of like feelings
like I go far enough with feelings
where it converts to the
inability to be canderous.
And I've gotten way better,
I give my brother credit, AJ.
He came into it when we started Vayner
he was much better at candor.
Life, like just like back
to muscles, like, you know,
it wasn't working because
when I would fire somebody,
they'd be shocked, they're like,
"A week ago, you told me it
was the best person on earth.
"Fuck you, Gary, you're fucking!"
And I was like, fuck!
You know, I thought I
was doing a good thing
by saving the person a job for a year,
but now I'm a bad guy?
Like, you know, you go
through it, you go through it.
So don't think it's a fucking problem.
You were built to be insecure.
You don't have to stay
insecure in perpetuity.
- That's true.
- What you have to do is reframe life
and not value other people.
Not value them, I mean it.
Do not put people on a pedestal.
You can admire things.
But like, I'm telling you,
it, once you realize we're all on,
we're just fucking humans,
we're on a level playing field,
all of a sudden,
by not over-admiring them,
you're not beating yourself up
for what you're not good at.
- True and it'll help me help them
at a more effective level
because I don't have that
in the background as well.
- Yeah, and by the way,
even the thought of helping them,
goes away, because you don't,
you're not even thinking
about helping them
as the crutch, in the relationship graph.
You see where I'm going?
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, that makes sense, yeah.
So now that's it right there.
- Because that's,
your, your way to,
when you admire something
or you think something better is like,
"Okay, I'm gonna help them."
"That's going to, that's,
like, that's gonna even us."
- Yeah, yeah, brings you up, right?
- That's your leverage,
"Hey, let me help you."
They're like, "They're
not asking for help."
- Right, right, yeah.
- And I see this, bro,
you are like drilling everything for me.
I can't believe you even just said that.
I knew I wanted to keep you on here.
Like, I'm telling you, you know what,
you're helping a lot of people, Chris.
There's a lot of you.
Chris, there's a lot of
Chris Duggers in the world.
- Sure.
- I see them all the time.
And you know what's funny?
I love them.
I'll tell you why.
You noticed how earlier
I said your compassion, your kindness?
- Yeah, that was weird.
- And I could feel it because I know you.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I see you a lot.
And I see a lot of them in my company.
I see them a lot in my friend graph.
You need to work on your insecurity.
You're not tricking anyone,
and "I'm gonna help them"
is trying to trick them
into a level playing field
'cause you're so insecure
of your actual truth
of your capability.
- Alright.
- It's posturing.
- Yeah, yeah, in a way.
Yeah, that's it and yeah.
- Good news, not in a way.
It's 100% posturing.
And here's where it really, really sucks.
You trick, the people
you don't care about.
And you expose yourself to
the people you do care about.
- Ooh, I got some work to do.
- Not work, opportunity, brother.
This is good.
You know.
- I like it working.
So I yeah, let's go, it's good.
- But do you understand?
It's okay.
- Yeah.
- Like it's, like it's good.
- Yeah, no.
It is, it is you're right, you're right.
And it's an insecurity and a posturing
that I didn't realize I
was, I was doing, man.
- The reason I know you were doing it is,
as we talked as I listen,
you know, it's that "I'm gonna
get into this person's lane.
"I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm
gonna help that person."
These are cliche.
- No so what's really interesting
is someone just said,
"Be your authentic self."
And I always thought that
that was my authentic self
because I do enjoy helping people so much,
and I truly believed it's okay --
- I believe that, but I do too.
And I don't seek it out, it comes to me.
That's the difference.
- Ah yeah, yeah.
- You're seeking out the --
- And I'm starting
to get the whole, it's coming to me now.
So I'm starting to see it a little bit.
So thank you for helping
me along with that,
'cause that's just gonna
help it come even more.
- Chris listen to me.
You're fucking awesome dude.
I can smell it and taste
it through the computer.
What you need to do,
is lead with your shortcomings,
not try to disguise them.
- Yes, sir.
Might take a while but I'll
be on it man, I'll be on it.
- I love, you know what?
That was my favorite thing you said.
I'm gonna just,
I don't know if you see the goosebumps.
(laughs)
I love you for recognizing,
it's not going to be one talk
with Gary Vee and tomorrow.
But listen to me.
It's not as hard as you think.
Once you make that, this
is why I use this word.
You're not tricking anyone, Chris.
- You're right.
- The people, the people like
when you're doing your
peacocking and posturing,
you think it's working,
and what's happening behind your back
is the conversations are not
what you want them to be.
- That's true, and now you
know the reason for my hair,
it's the peacock.
(laughs)
- Brother, I'm proud of you.
Like you should get comfortable with this.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- It's something
you don't need to be uncomfortable with.
You don't need to like hair like,
get comfortable with it, it's you.
You understand?
That's why this is powerful.
You don't need to deflect.
You don't need to convert it into,
the hair is a peacock.
It's you, you're fucking awesome.
- Yeah, yeah, thank you, yeah absolutely.
And like I, like I said,
it's just it's gonna take a while
for me to work on it, but --
- It is gonna take a while,
but the biggest thing
I think I've given you
and I hope you can build
on it with somebody else
is you're not tricking anyone.
And good news,
this video is gonna be
watched by a million people
over the next three years,
so you're definitely not gonna hide.
(laughs)
And that's the best thing
that happened to you,
not the worst.
- Yeah, I know.
- Once you,
and the four or five, seven people I love
that I'm thinking about right now,
in my companies and friend
circles and contemporaries
realize how real this fucking talk was,
the whole world's gonna get better.
You're not tricking anyone.
- Ah we need a real world man.
We need more real,
so thanks for helping
me be even more real.
Helping my shit out.
I appreciate it Gary.
- It's a good thing, man.
You know why?
There's nothing to be embarrassed of.
So what?
So you don't go into every situation
thinking you're gonna crush it.
Who gives a fuck?
So you're not the leader,
or the fucking fixer
that you think you are.
Who gives a fuck?
You can be, if you get real with yourself,
and realize you're not there yet.
And realize you can't talk your way
or act your way out of it.
You're gonna be seen for your truth
by the smartest emotional people
who are really running shit anyway.
So where the fuck are we going?
- Round in circles really, at that point.
- Correct, that's why
you're at where you're at.
- Yeah.
- And what's awesome
is you're a fucking child.
- Yeah.
- You're a fucking child.
- 31.
- The best part of this whole conversation
is literally everything that's happened
up to this second doesn't mean shit.
Like all that garbage,
like that you're thinking about right now,
good news!
There's no time machines,
you can't go back anyway.
Why don't we focus on the
next 71 years of your life?
Where you fucking own
this all the way through
and go fucking ham
on your fucking actual authentic self,
not the authentic self that
you're looking to present,
so people don't actually know
the truth of what's going on.
- Yeah, let's go.
Yeah, and you know what, I
DM you all the time anyway,
it's kind of like a cathartic thing.
So I'll keep pace with you on this, Gary.
Like I'm gonna work on this and --
- Do me a favor.
Chop this, chop this turn it
into audio and listen to it.
It will help you, man.
Here's why.
I want the reminder to know,
every time you're doing something,
that nobody's getting fooled.
- Ooh, we're getting uncomfortable.
Ooh let's go okay.
(laughs)
- I get it though, I know you man.
I could, I sensed you from like,
and you're fitting
something that's really.
The reason we're so deep on this one,
and I'm going so deep,
and I appreciate you sitting with me.
'Cause it is uncomfortable.
And I respect you to.
You cannot imagine how much I admire you,
with the strength to sit through this.
- Wow, okay, thank you.
(laughs)
- Seriously, who the fuck
wants to be on the spot
being poked at their zit like this?
I admire you tremendously.
(laughs)
- Bro I'm admiring your
feedback, I mean a lot.
And this is,
this is so incredible
that like I've just I'm here
from a position of learning so.
- Bro I think you could,
I really think you can pull this off.
What you need from me is the reminder
that unless you go completely you,
it's not gonna work.
- That's true.
- And so it's gonna have, short-term
you trick that person
you trick this person,
but like, somewhere along the line,
it's gonna get exposed
and depending on the emotional
intelligence of the person,
I fucking understood you in four seconds,
you didn't say shit.
- Yep, true.
- 'Cause I'm on some Yoda
shit with my EQ, right?
But --
- That's true.
But I have no reading comprehension.
I don't feel like I'm special,
it's just I feel like it
was what I was handed.
And then somebody else
who might not be emotionally intelligent,
you might be able to trick them
for a year, for two years.
But eventually it's gonna happen.
- Dude it --
- And so,
what I'd rather, right,
you see where I'm going?
- Yeah, and it goes across
like your whole life.
Like the most authentic person that I am,
like my most authentic
self is with my wife.
And it's like my most
successful relationship by far.
- I love that.
Bro, you've completely
won the love of everybody.
This is your, this is
your handle right here?
- Yeah, I it's actually
all of 24 hours old,
like I said, I'm doing this all myself so
and I haven't really
done any sort of like design
or anything like that so.
- Do it, nobody gives a
fuck about your design, bro.
- Perfect.
- Nobody gives a fuck about the design.
Stick with me, no more
valuing their opinions.
You know how I think about logos?
I don't give a fuck.
Poor Robbie Deeks, we announced
Vayner commerce yesterday.
He like got super sad,
like a week ago when,
when like the team showed
him the first logo.
And he's like, "You approve this?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
He's like, "This is dog shit."
I'm like, "Like who gives a fuck?"
Logos are made, names are made.
Your logo is not the
variable of your success.
Your fu manchu is not the
You know, don't let other
people's opinions have any weight.
Be who you are, and go and execute.
Let, let the results speak,
not the people's opinions upfront.
I prefer, when people think
I can't pull shit off.
You know, Chris, that I'm
in a weird part of my life
where my level of success and notoriety
has now put me in a place
where people think I'll be successful
in everything I launch and I hate it.
- Well yeah.
- Do you know how much fun,
do you know how much fun I?
Yeah, but guess what, bro?
That's the reverse of you.
Like, like, I like underdog.
I like people shitting on me.
- Yeah.
- I would actually argue
I'm the reverse of you
and I posture down.
One of the things I don't
like about Tea With Gary Vee
is I'm getting a lot of emails of like,
"Hey, you're much smarter than I thought."
"Hey, you're more
thoughtful than I thought."
And I'm like, "Fuck,
they're figuring me out."
Because I like the, "Oh,
I'm crazy, I'm stupid."
You know, like, I kinda like
the rope and dope of like not,
'cause I don't have pride in my intellect.
I have pride in my
humility and giving back.
- And that's where I wanna be.
That's where I feel like
I'm operating at of like --
- Yeah, bro, but you
can't be you can't give
until you're fucking in a good place
and you're not in a good place.
- Yeah you right.
- You're, I know brother!
You're fake giving as a leverage point
to subsidize your
insecurity and inferiority.
But you don't have to be.
This is the moment,
we can literally, listen.
You were fucking right about meeting me.
This is the moment.
I'm not letting you go
'cause I'm not done,
I'm trying to fucking
change your life forever.
- Well yeah and --
- Because one conversation
can do it.
- Ah this is mind blowing!
(laughs)
This is crazy.
But now this means that
I'm gonna have to do a --
- Yes, yes.
See what I'm doing you,
is I'm giving you the gift of suffocation.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know everybody else around you
has enabled you to still
play into the creases.
I'm trying to smoke you the fuck out.
Because smoking you the fuck out
is actually how you start
getting to happiness.
- I feel pretty smoked, not gonna lie.
Sitting like some people
are here right now.
My mouth is dry, man,
I can't even handle it.
- Yeah listen, I deployed some real smoke,
you know, like, I get it.
I brought my big smoke pack.
You know why?
'Cause I love you and I
think this will really work.
- Hey, man, I love you
too for what you do.
And I, this is incredible, thank you.
- You're welcome--
- Very very much
in the line of like truly
the gratitude right now is
(mumbles) thank you.
- Listen, brother,
Chris, last parting shot.
Recognize that this will be
watched over a million times,
so you're not gonna be
able to hide anyway.
So who cares?
So let's, it's over.
This shadow game, the
manipulation game, the like
trying-to-find-the-angle-so-people-don't-know
game?
It's over.
- It's actually really nice.
- It's the greatest gift of all.
- It's actually really, really nice.
- No, no brother, it's the medicine
that everybody that's wired
like you actually needs,
but nobody wants to go there.
- It's uncomfortable, it is.
- Of course it is.
And it's easier when you're
a little more disconnected, right?
The reason I struggle with
this candor with people I love
is 'cause I'm connected.
So I don't judge your mom,
your wife, your best friend,
'cause I'm not capable of it either
on that intimate of a level of feelings,
but I'm very capable of it,
maybe the best at it,
when it comes to this.
- Yeah you --
- Because I can
read people so fast.
I can read so fast,
and so even within this 60 minutes,
I can get it off.
- Yep.
Yeah, no, that makes,
makes a lot of sense.
Well, today's my content creation day so.
I think I'm gonna --
- Every day, good news.
Every, once you actually hear me out,
every day is gonna be
your content creation day,
because once you go into confidence,
you're always creating
because you're not
worried about the results
on the other side of the creation.
Why am I able to produce so much content?
'Cause I don't give a fuck
when a piece of content doesn't succeed.
I don't think twice when
something doesn't perform.
I don't stop when somebody says
I'm full of shit or I suck.
You got it?
- I totally get it.
I have a ton of fun creating
content too, so why?
- You just don't want like,
you're just insecure with the feedback.
- You're totally right, no, 100%.
- I know.
- Yeah, yep.
- I know you and I love
you, the you, the most.
I know you,
and out of all the people
that run in the different groups
of 55 different kind of things, 100.
It's you who I love the most,
because there's a kindness
and a insecurity
that creates this really
interesting personality trait
that I can see from this screen with you,
and I have a lot of love for you,
and I really want you to win,
and this is the singular conversation
that I've seen over my years of life
that actually helps that person.
- Yeah, how does it not like?
(laughs)
How does it not?
I'm floored, I don't even have
anything left to say, Gary.
- Alright brother.
Just go and do it.
Go read your DMs.
A lot of these people are hitting you up.
This is a really kind community.
This might be the virtual
community that helps you prop up,
but do me a favor, Chris.
Watch this over and over,
and just if you remember anything,
you're not tricking anyone,
and not anyone you want to be tricking.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You gotta change up
your whole script.
You know, you just
you're, you're just not.
You're not pulling it off.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I know what you mean,
I 'cause I'm here where I'm at
and we're talking right
now so clearly I'm not.
And it's ringing true to me.
So yeah, that's a truth.
That's how you figure out
it's the truth, right?
- Yeah.
- Cross-check it.
- And like, the common thing
with guys and gals like you
is they fool the least
emotionally intelligent,
and so that's their, they
think they're pulling it off,
but what they're losing with
is the most emotionally intelligent,
and emotional intelligence
is the alpha of our society,
and so you need to really understand that.
- Yeah, yeah. I need to --
- And by the way,
you just, you know, you didn't,
it didn't work in a work environment
because eventually somebody's boss or boss
or your direct boss understands that.
So that's not gonna work.
And it's not gonna work with your business
'cause you're not gonna fool customers.
They're gonna see right through it.
And the customers you're going to get
are going to be the least
emotionally intelligent,
which are gonna be sucky customers,
and then the whole thing's gonna break.
Or you listen to this over and over
every day for the rest of your life
until you don't need me no more.
And you fucking are the
reverse version, which is,
you're comfortable with losing,
you're comfortable, you
know, with not succeeding.
You don't worry about
the judgment anymore,
even though you grew up in an environment
where the judgment over was overvalued,
you start chipping away at that
and creating a new version of yourself.
And you can, because
really you have no choice.
You have no choice 'cause
you know I'm right.
And you have no choice
because a million people gonna watch this
and you're gonna be
able to hide in society.
(laughs)
- That's true, it's 100% true.
So yeah, I've just gotta
I've got to get to work.
And I'll hammer it home on this.
Alright?
- I believe you.
That's why I'm sticking here so long.
I weirdly believe you.
Update me in a year, brother.
I love you.
- Definitely will.
Love you back, Gary,
thank you so much, man.
- Okay, bye bye.
- That was good.
(laughs)
We have Brett in door
number one that's back,
or would you like to go
with this lovely couple,
Jason and Kelly in door number two?
- I'm going to, I'm gonna wrap up,
we're gonna get them on for tomorrow.
- Okay.
- I've only got eight minutes,
and you know, it's kind
of like, you ever see
like in those like superhero
movies where like, the,
you know all the Sci-Fi stuff,
like the person gives all the energy
but then they're like, like, this is like,
this is like the episode where like,
I, you know.
- Just, wind down --
- Yeah, yeah,
I'm just, I'm just gonna wrap up.
- Okay.
- I appreciate it everybody.
I'm sorry to cut it short,
but I left it all on
the field on that one.
So I hope you have a wonderful day.
Please let me know
if you got value out of that last session.
(chuckles)
Please, please hit me up on Twitter.
I've got a few minutes
before my next thing.
I could really use the comments.
Here's my Twitter.
Lot of you don't hit me up on Twitter,
please hit me up on Twitter.
I'd really, I'd really,
I'd like to talk to you 'bout that.
I'd like to see how many people.
Yeah, thank you for watching.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I am giving away, the
ultimate Gary Vee experience.
How should I go, okay.
Over the last week or so
I've been jammin' with
my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now!
But, allinchallenge.com, please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all-time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry,
during this ridiculous time.
And so now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction the ultimate
GaryVee experience.
Here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head:
and you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this, I am giving away.
Okay, you get to, in the course of a year,
you will go garage sailing with me,
and film "Trash Talk."
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti,
so I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also, we're gonna go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna pay my dad.
(laughs) Well, I'm gonna donate,
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000.
So $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories,
and you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me.
I never do this, when I
give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me.
So you will sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game,
I'm completely focused.
But you'll get that.
So the ultimate Jets experience, tailgate,
full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you one week play
at VaynerMedia, so this is for you
and a plus one by the way.
So the two tickets,
we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and you,
depending on what is.
One full week at VaynerMedia,
getting consulting
and business advice
from Team GaryVee and me
for the entire week,
hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest on my podcast.
We're going to do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club
in New York City.
And I'm going to fly
you, all paid, plus one,
to three of my keynotes, and
we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved.
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also, what's so fun about
the All-In Challenge is,
you get to challenge people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge
all the VaynerSports athletes.
I expect you in there,
so that is number one,
number two, I'm gonna go with,
ooh, you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
Timbaland the super producer
I'm calling you out.
And finally
I got one.
The Undertaker.
One of the great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com
Please support this, the
experiences are gonna be nuts!
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs
for the last week putting
this all together.
You're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media.
#allinchallenge.
Please check it out and
please go to your favorite
celebrities, athletes and entertainers
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All-In Challenge.
Please, take it.